schweisgut bei der wehr war läuft weil
ich hab' ich hab so ein tolles kreuz aus
diamant blöcken bei mir schon darauf
gestellt
die vorbereitung ist das war 1000
prozentig re wie einfach es war einfach
wie das kann ich schwören
was ist das ziel für mich heißt rumäne
ich hasse dich was was ist das was die
saturn
ist seine neuen mega projekt folge und
damit dabei ist heute der lukom kräfte
halten
wir haben uns einen kleinen sozialen
plan gepasst ich erst mal machen möchte
ist weil bei dir bei den tresoren mich
noch mal selbst davon überzeugen
das kann ja nicht sein nun also anleger
erst einmal nicht gleich eine festung
gebaut
das ist geil dieser weg endlich habe ich
mal wieder weg zu meinem haus art weg
gemacht ich hab doch kein weg zu meinem
haus ich hab mich vertan unterricht
gemacht so was können wir auch machen
sowas soziales ihr habt schon ich hab
schon nur soziales gemacht letzter zeit
wollen doch was soziales machen
während überlegt ja gesagt ja klar da
gama jascha los und worum geht es denn
mal lieber ich habe man es geht um
kuchen es geht wir wollten benjamin
blümchen tod worte machen hätte ich dich
heute erwartet hätte ich das haben wir
das anders
die haben das in der schule gesungen na
ja immer hätte ich dich heute war opel
ich kann meine eigenen selbst nicht
offen öffnen kuchen hab ich kann die
nicht öffnen
ich habe am besten ich hab sogar an alle
die meinten du ihn von hinten kann er da
dran
guckt euch das an ich habe einen traum
eingesetzt und von unten irgendein auch
an den hinteren kann nicht drangehen
herrlich haben sie drin öffnen
hey ich kann in unseren einfach mal
öffnen ich kann den anderen auch öffnen
kannst du den hintersinn öffnen
mit der erst mal kommen crafter bislang
alipour dann habe ich die alle nicht
geöffnet damit die nicht meine sind
optimal hingesetzt schreiben dass sie
erst öffnen
jetzt helfe es auch bei den kontrakt ak
lieber herr tillich welcher der sunday
der untere jahr da kannst du fix dran
weil du hast gerade aufgemacht afrikas
die auf gemacht deswegen scheiße dann
habe ich das vergessen die aufzumachen
bei den kanu mit einer ranch abbauen nur
spitzer grenz tappen die abgebaut bin
dabei
wer hat eine branche brennt kann man das
der ranch ab und sicher funktioniert
grad bei mir nicht ich mach's mit einer
spitzhacke luft nicht in meinen gang
weniger anlauf nicht in meinen weg von
graphen her nicht alter du brauchst ein
wörtchen ranch für das geht wirklich
nicht siehst
china unicom ist eine ranch also mein
ranches april ich weiß noch recht habe
ich sondern nur noch 15 ersatz der
erzählt erst mal ganz kurz was wir
machen wollen
also wir dachten uns das ganze megabyte
bedarf mal wieder etwas mehr frieden und
harmonie und dazu dachten wir uns
vorstellen einfach mal eben bewohner ein
kuchen und einem diamant locken und
sagen einfach mal laufen und so peace
und zufrieden alter was geht bei der
wehr erwartet läuft ich hab' ich hab so
ein tolles kreuz aus diamant blöcken bei
mir schon drauf gestellt sollte wowereit
und b ist das war 1000 prozentig re wie
einfach es war einfach wie das kann ich
schwören
ich könnte wetten dass war wie hayoz
einen diamant blog von mir eingesammelt
du ach ich bin bei wobei ich habe aus
versehen an sich ein schuss gelöst das
war ein portal aus versehen junge jetzt
kassierst du also wo bin ich denn ich
komme genau mit diesem hass gesät
rausgekommen bin ja bei dem laverton ich
bin auch hier
nee ich bin genau da rausgekommen beim
portable holt wo die kühe standen hinter
uns jetzt früher nächste keine kühe hier
wenn dann sind sie gestorben
hier ist fleisch gut macht
ich habe knapp die führung gebracht ok
ich gebe jetzt wirklich vorteil
ach ja portal nach zahl alter ich bringe
das hab ich hab bin wieder zurück weil
ich oh mann ich hasse das ich muss gegen
gedrückt was funktioniert bei denen ich
ja ich bin ich bin da ich bin da ich bin
hier
du hast ein diamant blog von mir war
egal weil die sind ja für einen
gemeinnützigen zweck ein gemeinnütziger
zweck macht mobil denn du bist nicht bei
mir ich bin nicht bei dir nein das
schwierige werden nicht die diamant
blöcke seien davon haben wir schon sechs
und wenn der kuchen
was braucht man den fuhr ich weiß ich
werde es also vergessen so eine art
hände locker easy kuren ok es gibt
kleine und großen kuchen gibt mag ein
cache also grundschulden kuchen machen
okay es gibt zwei verschiedene größen
gibt einfach kein großer so groß den
braucht man genau gleich da man den
genau gleich macht denke ich ich glaube
das ist nur irgendwie so ein fehler das
genau was bitte ist das ein komisches
ding hier
sie wollen einfach nur hinsetzen nur
eingebaut der kamele hochspringen alter
gail davis cup saison hoch geschleudert
ist das so ein parcours an
hier also man muss nichts machen 8
stellt sich einfach dahin ja nah kommt
man nach oben und dann ist man auf caps
geheimer base wo er sein radio hat wo er
so mega stoffes alter wie geil geil geil
das bitte ist das schießen als helfer
man radio beiseite mit dir also
produktiv jetzt will ich sie machen
brauchen eier kühe und damit wir bauen
mega viele kühe weil über und mega viel
jünger um say nicht
wir brauchen eine kuh müssen das craften
wo wir brauchen eine kuh däne aber ganz
viele eimer
ja genau nein nein bordeaux 3 1 oder
sechster hielt gleichzeitig kräften
können
ach ja drei er 63 mal habe ich aber noch
ich habe ich habe locker 12 einmal oder
so wieso laufe ich denn jetzt zu dir und
sugar und und und und weizen
also leute ich bin ich wohl zum brocken
fans laufen passt denn ordentlich weizen
weizen müsste ich haben nein die kühe
die die hühner seien alle tot
ja die habe ich abgeschlossen ich krieg
die krise hier mit diesen gefunden
die haben doch bestimmt hier drin oder
müssten die eigentliche feier
ich habe einzig ab 46 mega geil auf
jeden fall gebrauchen allerdings auch
wir brauchen eier brauchen wir wir
brauchen ja für einen kuchen wir
brauchen ja wie viele grundstücke gibt
es überhaupt es gibt es gibt ein problem
ich dachte jetzt grade werden so acht
leute person
wir sind eher locker 20 oder so ja was
ist denn das hier fünf high school
rumäne ich hasse dich was was ist das
was die natur versieht milliarden
prozentig was broken fast das 2 1 anders
sind glaube ich das war nur im alter ein
wett hochbaum gemacht habe die penner
nein ich hab ich habe mir den beiden
ich wollte die solarpanels zu bauen und
dann habe ich einfach den solarpanel auf
die höchste erreichbare stufe gesetzt
oben auf höhe 200 oder so deswegen
hatten die energie dann haben die nicht
wahrscheinlich gefragt zuhörer warum
und jetzt hat sich das bei mir gemacht
aber die haben die haben sich einfach
nicht die mühe gegeben
der blog ist sogar noch darüber den
solarpanels von denen und dann haben die
sich bei mir wahrscheinlich gedacht
super ich konnte nicht mal so hoch mit
jetpack ich muss mich da
nein ich muss ich dann eben hoch stecken
sie man hatte doch ganz ganz viele
hühner wo sind denn die ich weiß wo ich
auch voll witzig wenn alle hier einfach
in den scheiß auf meinen auf meine kappe
drauf bauen auch megageil ich habe das
noch nie gemacht noch nie
na waie nahm sein mag simon 0
genau hier waren seine wiener und jetzt
sind also ich höre die ver di wat
eigentlich sind zwar aber es kann sich
alle 100 noch richtig viele denn da geht
doch nicht aber jetzt bin ich da lol ja
in rechtenbach eine ganze kiste voll mit
eiern
natürlich wollen uns die kiste einfach
mal kurz mitnehmen damit bin ich rüber
fliegen müssen
ja herr bauer noch nicht so viele aus
scheiße was tust du alter ich habe eine
kiste wein maschmann portal auch sofort
aber ich mache ja nicht so gut weil wenn
hühner da reingehen
nee also portal einfach also als auch
nicht gut okay was auch gelang denn da
doch was eigentlich einmal darin stecken
bleibt
ok ich hoffe ich habe jetzt in der kiste
eier darin bot den laster voll gut das
thema soziale aktion macht aber aber
kann es sein dass du nur ressourcen von
anderen leuten
ich finde es echt cool aber du wirst
sehen wie trotzdem voll das arschloch
wissen was der sozialaktion uns die
sachen für die sozialaktion von anderen
ja aber sie mal mehr erlaubt die marke
kann alles zu nutzen was hab ich lieber
hsg mal die mal dann das portal unten
das ist megageil
wow ich verstehe dass meine rüstung
kaputt gemacht hat ich weiß eigentlich
ist man instant tot aber ich wusste dass
quantum arme hast von daher ist trotzdem
sehr schnell kaputt gegangen auf lan
alter manchmal derbe weg ab wandert mich
ich mache das in der von mir gebauten
sozialen ladestationen also bei der
dinge ist ja aber das war die
sozialaktion wirkt die ressourcen hat ja
jeder unter märkten manchmal wenn man
die ressourcen nicht mehr hat das ding
ist nur dass niemand bock hat das allzu
kräften besser und blog aber ich denke
die leute freuen sich auf jeden fall
mehr als ich habe zwei folgen da haben
wir dass die dinge geachtet nur so dumm
um die kräftig drauf die jedenfalls
haben wir uns jetzt gedacht dass wir
einfach mal eben diamant block und
kuchen hinsetzen damit diese denken war
diamant blog scheiße den kann ich nicht
essen aber hey das ein kuchen einfach
nur deswegen herr irgendwas kann bei
diesen charge fett noch machen hätte man
sicher irgendwann kannst du da noch
machen damit das irgendwie so schneller
lädt weiß bescheinigt was ich meine
ja ich weiß was zum einen fake woher
weiß das wie habe ich ein bett im
internet abgebaut
dank dam dam egal zwischen doppel wird
ja bloß backup 1 abgebaut
ich will dich hab einfach der weg auf
den boden wollte ich mir auch noch
machen
aber egal jetzt erst mal um weizen und
darf kümmern
also was dinge ist ja wollen ich habe
doch schon weizen man wir brauchen jetzt
nur noch die kuh war eindeutig beweist
dass nicht mehr wohl
da wo die anderen dinge waren aber eine
kuh glaube ich wo welche anderen dinge
war
da wo diese hühner zeugs mal recht
bestand also nico 0 wie viele monster
hier sind läuft bei dir sicher dass da
keine kuh war ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher
dann schauen wir jetzt nach so langer
das wird eine pay day maske normal als
fünf forschen und darunter ist gomez
kopf weiter sagt gestört da wir müssen
jetzt wieder dahin gehen wo die halt so
wo auch immer die sena ich doch dass sie
gern studiert damit jetzt ich glaube
dass intelligenz studiert hast du das
willst du hier
euro nach oben dann hier die at hoch und
wobei telefonie unten war niko maedge
stoff intelligenz ja ich konnte leider
nicht unter der ist eine kuh ja meine
pilzkunde die kann man doch auch
benutzen oder nicht eltern schnauze ab
wahrscheinlich doch pilze geht ja nur
nur wenn du mit einer bildschirm
hingehst macht die pilzsuppe raus
ansonsten macht die ganz normale milch
ich hab noch nie so glück als sechs
eiern zwei hühner hast jetzt ein ding
dabei oder nicht weiß nicht wie man da
bestimmt was oder heran hatte ich kann
ich kann auch eben von mir holen
ich kann das ding ich bin auf dem weg zu
dir mann bin gekommen
ich bin mir selber einmal gefunden
wenn ich hier nicht funktioniert der
funktioniert nicht herauslaufen wieder
an dies zu groß dafür kann ihn nicht
kann ich meiner nicht kaputt machen
mach sie nicht kaputt weil wir immer
mama du hast jetzt muss gucken menschen
respekt ja ich habe sieben natürlich
dollar nimmt einfach alles mit
oder hat statt 1 3 1 4 in kraft ist
einfach immer wie hass auch so eine
geile working crafting mensch zeigt ja
du musst einfach alles um reinalter aber
es läuft das latif mussa kussa apfel
rauswerfen weil sonst ist einfach nur
einfach alle zutaten die pastell uns
untere feld und dann ordner oben dass
das an was mir so sehr ich brauche okay
wir brauchen sind solche sachen
hast du doch zuckerrohr ja klar irgendwo
den holzkisten glaube ich morgen aber
viel weiß wo ich schreib mir ist lieber
aus you met ehrlich dazu suchen
die heißen dass thomas wir brauchen nur
so wenig eier zu erkennen ob ich weiß
wir brauchen ja gar nicht so viel wie
ich mitgenommen habe nee du mich wieder
total als ich brauchte mal kurz hockey
meter ja das war auf jeden fall keine
verschwendung aufgabe gemacht habt sex
jetzt oder warte mache ich den boden mit
sandy bridge alter sieht auch ein eis
aus
ich mach das also zumindest in dem text
mexikos okay einen krohn haben wir schon
ja ich selbst normal der kuchen oder ist
irgendwie so klein dass normal es gibt
keinen großen kuchen aber wie geplant
zwei verschiedener größen ist der wird
im größeren bild auf jeden fall okay wir
haben den bogen gemacht was mit dem geld
neue was bauen jetzt neue milch ich
drücke ich die den kuchen im inventar
raus erst noch mehr dinge machen solche
maschine
ich mache schon mal schilde naja ok
brauchen mehr milch mehr milch braucht
das land
man kann kuchen stärken dass ich nervig
ein schön
wieso habe ich bitte nur ein schild doch
für seine milch ich glaube ich mach mir
stellte jupiter geht gar nicht so falsch
wenn du mich brauchst dass das geht gar
nicht
ich kann kann ich mir eigentlich kann
ich mir eigentlich mama hat gesagt ich
kann alles welchen auf festen glauben
dena wie sieht eigentlich eine zombie
maske auswendig eine maske schon oft
habe ich dann nur hinten sonst kommt es
zum die dinge oder wenn was ich habe
eine zombie maske auf hab ich aber sonst
eine maske sieht das aus komisch oder
von hinten hast du zum zombie und wann
wirst du bist ein zombie mit einem
villiger kopf unterbricht um aus und
müll
ich hab noch weizen für dich minuten ich
brauch keinen weiß nicht warum ich
brauche hier um bastelt ihr zuckerrohrs
youtube ich habe hier 46
nebeneinanderliegen kilo aber richtiger
dem alter form liegt ja weil das müll
ist das nervig ist er dann mit dem
ganzen den ganzen immer so brav meist
ansonsten einfach viel mehr heime ja
wirklich einmal wir brauchen eine kraft
doch hier schon kuchen man kann ja mit
japan ein
dann schnappe ich habe hier alleine
machen
ich brauche mein haus und ja das ist
nicht für die allgemeinheit ok schule
sitzt du endlich vor mir das recht ich
bin ja ich lebe noch und stühle und
harte erde franches von hilfsbedürftigen
leuten
und nicht behilflich oder was auch immer
doch war ich aber hier die biester
quatsch alter so viel müll ich muss dir
soviel jupiter wegwerfen aber trotzdem
ja denn ich wollte trotzdem sagen war
okay akzeptiert deswegen
wir wollten dem thema bequatschen aber
ich habe das in der nächsten folge da
sind wahrscheinlich
wir machen so kapp machen wir nicht so
ja egal was los landmann jetzt okay
jetzt setzen wir auch den kuchen überall
hin und so weiter und bürger fühlen da
fühlst du schon heute ein bisschen
action mal macho